yeah and then obviously now you're
you're Twitch streaming full-time right
that's your much to my family's great
shame uh no my mom loves because yeah
yeah if you thought teaching was bad no
but I think you know Twitches or
streaming or YouTube or what any of you
guys have done podcasting it just it
just seems like every time I taught you
it's like streaming was like me yeah
yeah with all the experiences you have
and like your background and everything
yeah it's just you know you can Shine
the way you want to really well I
appreciate it seems that you have a very
interest I I like when you talk to me
about it because I find that because you
weren't raised online no well actually
before you guys you know I was raised
like on the base of the internet right
right like the beginning of AOL instant
messenger and e-bombs world and you're
the man now dog and things that don't
exist anymore that were memes way before
we had words for memes yeah um but then
I took a nine year break when it really
blew up yeah because from 2009 when 11
was the Toca earthquake yeah I didn't
even have a PC for eight years so I
missed of course you see it on the phone
and stuff but when when YouTube really
became a career in the late 2000s and it
kind of opened these opportunities on
Twitch like 2010 2011. I I was on the
sidelines on that and I you guys have
such knowledge of it but the things that
we had back then are still we dial up
and Net Zero and if you had DSL in your
your apartment blocks or your houses
everyone will just come over to your
house to use the internet oh yeah it was
a it was the wild west back then I think
it was the cooler yeah it was actually a
lot more fun I think how did you find
out about twitch then all right so it's
actually really interesting because no
it's not I don't know why but
I had been into watching like Justin TV
and stuff for Evo and fighting game
tournaments yeah and then twitch came
about when I had started teaching at a
high school and I started watching a
ridiculous amount of hearthstone during
the initial blow up of like twitch and I
started getting into all of that stuff
and then I started streaming myself a
little bit I bought a PlayStation Eye
camera and I tried and I I used the
indoor PlayStation live streaming I
tried I was like yeah I'm not feeling
this at all like it it was I wasn't
ready for that opportunity yet yeah I've
never seen somebody stream uh using the
built-in like streaming tools however
I've seen one I've tried it once I've
seen one person do it who had a
substantial viewership really you know
who it was no it was like uh he told me
uh the the Hitomi
he's pulling stuff yeah she was playing
uh if you don't know her yeah you might
know her you will know her you probably
don't know you know her yeah
um but yeah she I remember she still
streams on Twitch now yeah she just
plays fortnite wow it's a built-in
PlayStation seriously holy [__] no no
commentary nothing it's just her playing
fortnite and I guess people are just
like I could imagine every second it was
it was tough I was I remember OverWatch
just come out right and I I was playing
that on the built-in stream 16 doesn't
that feel crazy yeah [__]
[Music]
I was streaming that and I was playing
as Hanzo and I was you know I was kind
of like [__] Hans I mean well yeah at
least he's not a Genji mate yeah day one
of playing you know I was just feeling
it out you know I hadn't I'm a Zenyatta
man really the cool dude with the Rocks
I don't play OverWatch it's a pretty
game anyway but I was anyway I I was
doing this thing and I I hit some dude
with the head shot and you know
everyone's first stream I you know I was
like
hey good shot
and this guy somehow took the time to
like use the built-in PlayStation thing
and he was like you are [__] and I was
like yeah I am I was like what's up man
are you hello and then he never replied
and I was like oh maybe that was the one
and done you know that was it all right
but like it didn't feel right it didn't
feel fun it didn't have the things I
didn't have the tools available to make
it what I wanted what I'd seen yeah so I
was like yeah all right I'm done with
this and it wasn't until you know Kobe
that I got back into it but yeah it is a
very interesting platform for people
like me because it caters to what I grew
up with I think the most which I'm still
what I would consider a dying breed on
Twitch which is really centered on on
games and now I'm not saying that's not
popular of course but I think that what
twitch and YouTube streaming has done so
well is there's these people innovating
on it and doing bigger and more
interesting and like actual events right
yeah but I've always just wanted to
recreate a kind of game nights with my
buddies when we used to play Halo 16
player when I was in high school and
twitch does it was the best it was it
was the best of times having Lan parties
and land parties it was something that
unless you were there you you I'm very
jealous I never got I never got to
experience like Lan parties I used to
have Civ two land parties back in like
God middle school is so [__] fun no
none of my friends games like all the
guys knew how to set that up yeah man it
was like because those days you I didn't
even have an Xbox right but I had a big
enough basement so that everybody could
come over and bring their Xboxes people
we'd bring three TVs so people would
have to move there and this is not flat
screens these are not so these big asses
monsters yeah and we'd throw those in
the back and you'd bring I had my own
controller because you know there was
there was even wireless controllers yet
you just had like a wrapped up thing
yeah and we would we would all bring
over uh everybody had to bring over two
cases of soda that was the rule two
cases
every Midwest kid has a refrigerator in
the garage as well yeah so we would have
250 260 cans in there and more and then
we'd have the four TVs two in one room
and then two in my bedroom and they
would all be connected with four feet
eight on eight or whatever you were
playing yo we would start at like seven
seven thirty and stop 12 hours later my
mom would go to work on Saturdays and I
cannot believe she let us do this every
Friday for about 18 months that just
sounds like literally the best thing
it was great it was but you know a large
when online gaming came out we all
thought this is it this is going to be
great we can have game night anytime
it's not the same and um the novelty
wore off pretty quick because part of
it's just being in a room and
experiencing something exciting and uh
twitch is as close as I've ever felt
because of the interactive nature of it
and the the reactions and
um though I probably do a better job of
taking the channel in a different
direction I love my game nights and I
love doing those things and luckily
there's enough people who who still like
that stuff yeah I mean you say you say
it's a Dying Breed but I think you know
there's a a massive Market of people who
just want that like kind of simple as
you said like game night feel right like
it's uh you know whether it's built on
Nostalgia just the fact that like it's
like you know some people don't go to
Twitch to like see these like
extravagant events they just want
someone to hang out with that's yeah
that's a really good point yeah but yeah
yeah I mean like a lot of twitch is just
you know being online a lot and just
kind of like being there to fill in like
hanging out yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
like kind of like a friendship simulator
just hey just show up yeah there is a
nice element though for for me
personally where I I worked as a radio
DJ in America and I I did theater for a
long time and stuff and teaching to an
extent you do have that element of
performance time
and see if they hit or they did not and
uh yeah that to me is what keeps it
fresh and I am so thankful and humbled
that anybody even bothers to click that
so right it's a very it's a very
exciting thing to do I don't know man I
I tuned into your jumps jumping straight
and that was one of the funniest games
I've ever watched I've never seen
someone who is playing a rage game where
they're meant to rage and just come out
of it so positively I'm like you are in
so many ways the most positive dude I've
met him yeah
like you'd fall down five screens and
you're like that's that's okay let's do
it again again that's no Oddball on you
know Halo with 16 people that you want
to kill you and like it's it's I've been
through some of those fires but yeah to
me I realized early on I remember on one
of my early streaming days I was playing
like a Spider-Man game and I I it was
the Miles Morales one and I didn't think
the game was it was good but I did it
was too much of the same for me yeah and
I was like yeah I had like eight people
in there and stuff and I remember this
guy was like I was kind of talking [__]
on the game saying like well you know I
think they've already I thought I felt
like I've done this same city same
things yeah and this guy was like I
never talk in this chat but I was so
excited to see this game and I was so
excited to see you play it and I and uh
you've just been so negative and I
thought to myself
well thanks for watching the stream
we're ending now um but like that
actually resonated because I have a
choice right how I approach these things
and I could be upset and I could be
negative but I think that it's more fun
to find the positive stuff in my in my
experience yeah my British cogs in my
brain I totally get it but I totally get
it
that that really I was like you're right
I have a choice of what kind of content
that I I want to provide yeah so I'll
just keep I'll just keep doing and I
mean I do get angry occasionally but
like it's usually about my forehead size
or something oh you know they'll still
make fun of um the my physical
appearance but not in a bad way but like
you're like I was an oakamura Furniture
you know
I'm talking to El kante right now I'm
not gonna repeat to you yeah yeah
so yeah sometimes because you know we've
been on the internet for a long time we
uh have off had a have have had our Fair
show of like mean comments everything
like that so we're like immune to a lot
of it but sometimes you just get that
one comment I don't know maybe you just
like one thing you're worrying about
that one thing you are really really
worried about or insecure about and it's
it's happened to me like live on Twitch
and it's the worst When It Happens live
on Twitch because you kind of like you
go from instantly yeah let's [__] do
this stream to like I just want to like
end the stream yeah right now and I
don't know how to like mask that first
yeah for sure because with a YouTube
comment you're like [__] it I'm I'm
gonna be pissed for like an hour go have
like a nice meal or something I'm gonna
fight try and forget it and then you
wake up tomorrow like all right let's do
it we're on stream you're like [__] I'm
I'm still up I'm still on camera man
like smile through the pain smile
through the pain baby come on you can do
it sometimes you're streaming you're
like [__] I just for something for
whatever reason made you feel like [__]
maybe got a message that wasn't good
from someone who's like by the way your
house is burning down you know what I
mean like yeah occasionally you that's
why I tend to try and not check my phone
because sometimes you'll get a bad news
or something yeah something will get
canceled that you're looking forward to
and you're like well [__] my mood's kind
of ruined then now I gotta keep
streaming for two more hours at least
yeah I have to keep streaming for a
movie length and I sh and I'm not happy
yeah it's tough I'm pretty lucky I think
uh most people in this community I've
had has been so amazing and supportive
so I think like I I I I will get those
things but usually I'm like they're
right I I do need to exercise that's a
good point so I'll take that yeah you
you use it as a like a vehicle to kind
of add humor to the stream it does add a
lot of elements and it does make you
kind of like almost indestructible in a
sense to to insults because it's like
all right well if you're gonna make an
insult and I'm able to play it off and
make an add to the content yeah yeah
well then it's like what what can you do
really yeah someone really wants to for
some reason upset you I don't know why
they would I know it's a weird thing but
you know you put yourself out there and
it's it's just uh it's part of the
territory that does come with it you get
all the feedback good and bad it can be
very rewarding instantaneously
instantaneously that's what twitch does
and I think that that kind of field
makes it so hiding for me